DEEPLY.
THANK YOU.
JOINING US WITH MORE REACTION
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN.
DO YOU HAVE ANY REACTION TO WHAT
YOU HEARD FROM JOHN?
AND THE BIG BREAKING REPORT FROM
YESTERDAY?
>> IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
WE HAVE LOOKED INTO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION AND THE URANIUM ONE
THAT WE ASSIGNED A TASK FORCE
LEADER TO LOOK INTO THIS.
WE HAVE SEEN TROUBLING
INFORMATION.
I CAN'T VERIFY JOHN'S REPORTING.
HE ALWAYS DOES A GOOD JOB.
>> Sean: BACK TO HIS BREAKING
NEWS YESTERDAY.
WHAT WE DISCOVERED.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS WAS NOT
KNOWN WHEN WE CAN BACK 2 YEARS
THE CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
PHONEY DOSSIER.
THERE IS AN EMAIL CHAIN, JAMES
COMEY AND THE TOP-DOJ OFFICIALS
WERE ON AND THEY KNEW.
AND THE INTEL COMMUNITY HAD
ABOUT THE VALIDITY OF THE
DOSSIER WHICH YOUR MEMO POINT TO
AS THE BULK OF THE APPLICATIONS
FOR THE FISA WARRANT AGAINST
CARTER PAGE.
WHEN DID YOU FIRST FIND OUT
ABOUT THIS EMAIL CHAIN?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW THAT THE
EMAIL CHAIN IN JOHN'S REPORTING
IS THE SAME STUFF WE ARE LOOKING
AT.
ALTHOUGH IT SOUNDS VERY SIMILAR.
WE HAVE REQUESTED FOR MANY
MONTHS, THERE ARE EMAILS WHERE
THERE ARE REDACTIONS THAT WE ARE
QUITE CONVINCED THAT IF THAT IS
UNDEACTED AND PROVIDED TO THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AND THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, IT WILL
BE VERY CLEAR THAT THERE IS VERY
MUCH -- IT WAS VERY WELL KNOWN
THERE WAS A LOST INFORMATION
THAT WAS NOT PROVIDED TO THE
FISA COURT LEADING UP TO THE
WARRANT ON CARTER PAGE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO JOHN'S SOURCES
ARE, BUT I KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO GET THESE REDACTIONS
FROM EMAILS.
IT'S POSSIBLE WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE SAME TYPES OF EMAILS.
IT'S POSSIBLE THERE ARE MORE
EMAILS WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
WHAT WE ARE AWARE OF, THE 4th
BUCKET OF INFORMATION, IT WOULD
BE CLEAR THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE
WITHIN THE FBI AND THE DOJ THAT
KNEW WELL AND GOOD BEFORE THEY
WENT TO THE FISA COURT THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND OTHERS
WERE UP TO SOME REALLY BAD
ACTIVITIES.
>> Sean: THESE EMAILS WOULD BE
THE 4th BUCKET.
THE FISA APPLICATION THEMSELVES
PAGES 10 THROUGH 12 AND 17
THROUGH 34 AND THEN THE GANG OF
8 INFORMATION.
THESE ARE THE 4 BUCKETS.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
THE FIRST 3, THE PRESIDENT
CALLED TO HAVE DECLASSIFIED.
>> Sean: HE IS HOLDING IT BACK.
IF THEY KNEW AND IF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE KNEW THEY
WERE QUESTIONABLE.
THE WHOLE DOSSIER WAS
QUESTIONABLE AND IT WAS THE BULK
OF THE FISA APPLICATION AND THEY
USED IT ANYWAY.
THEY OMITTED THAT HILLARY
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR IT.
IS IT POSSIBLE THEY KNEW IT WAS
NOT TRUE AND GAVE IT TO THE FISA
COURT ANYWAY?
AND DIDN'T CORROBORATE IT AND
COMMITTED FRAUD ON THE FISA
COURT NOT ONCE BUT FOUR SEPARATE
TIMES.
ANYBODY SIGNING OFF AN
APPLICATION TO SPY ON AN AMERICA
THAT COULD LIKELY NOT BE TRUE?
>> YES, REMEMBER WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN LOOKING AT CRIMINALLY HAS
BEEN ABUSE OF POWER.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS A
CONSPIRACY TO ABUSE POWER.
HAVE YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT FOR A
LONG TIME.
WHAT THIS GETS INTO IT, THIS
WOULD BE THE FIRST CLEAR
EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE ON ANOTHER
MAJOR CRIME WHICH WOULD BE
CALLED LYING TO A FEDERAL JUDGE
WHICH IS A MAJOR CRIME.
>> Sean: THE PEOPLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT, THIS WOULD BE COMEY
SIGNING OFF ON IT AND ROD
ROSENSTEIN SIGNING OFF AND SALLY
YATES SIGNING OFF ON IT, RIGHT?
>> THEY ARE THE ONES THAT SIGNED
OFF ON IT.
THEY ARE NOT NECESSARILY THE WHO
KNOWS WHO PROVIDED AND DOCTORED
THE INFORMATION.
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE CULLPABLE
KNEW ABOUT THIS.
>> Sean: WILL YOU STILL HAVE THE
AUTHORITY AND ABILITY TO GET
THIS INFORMATION TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
>> YES.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THEY
WOULD BE THE REPUBLICAN LEADER
ON THE COMMITTEE.
THE QUESTION IS, THE SUBPOENA
POWER WILL LAY IN THE HAND OF
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE SENATE WOULD HAVE THE POWER
TOO.
WE HAVE FOR MANY MONTHS KNOW
WILLING -- WE SAID OUR
INVESTIGATION IS OVER WITH.
THE WHITE HOUSE CAN DECLASSIFY A
LOT OF THIS INFORMATION TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE DONE GREAT
WORK.
SO HAS JOHN SOLOMON.
SO WHAT I SAID IS TRUE.
THERE IS NO EQUAL JUSTICE.
EQUAL APPLICATIONS OF OUR LAWS.